hey it's evan today i'm answering a
question from one of my
youtube viewers tori who commented on my
evernote tutorial
best evernote tutorial i have found
thank you thank you so much
tori for the kind words any suggestions
for middle school or high school
students on organizing sections and tabs
this is such a great question uh
evernote was not around when i was in
high school i kind of wish it was
how i would do it is so if i'm here i'm
on my notebooks
i would look at creating a new notebook
for each
class that i'm taking and then a new
note
for every individual class every
individual topic within that class
here's how i do if i was doing it i
would go to my notebooks of course i've
got all this other stuff hacked in my
life
so i create a special stack just for it
you can't start with a stock right away
so you start with a notebook i would say
maybe call this history
so this is my notebook i would right
click on that and go add the stack
create a new stack and i would call my
new stack
school and then i could go down to
school
and i would create a new notebook for
every subject that i wanted to
create notes on so that could be you
know however many subjects students are
taking
within my history one so if i'm going to
history class every day
or every second day whatever it is i
create a new note
for every class or every main topic
within that history class remember when
i was in high school i used to
take notes with with a pen and paper i
didn't have a laptop in my high school
pen and paper and at the top of
every page what i would write is the
date so you should start a new
page so i do the same thing in evernote
and i would call it
november 22nd and
whatever we're learning maybe it's
talking about the war of
1812. and then start typing all my notes
and i'd have everything i need here
about the war of 1812 that i've learned
in that class
and then maybe you know next week i come
to class and we're talking about
something else
i would call that november 29th
and we're learning about um
you know world war ii
and take all my notes and put that in
there and then whenever
i need to review my notes i could
quickly find
anything i need either by date by topic
or i could do a full text search and
find anything that i wrote about
so that's how i do it again i'm creating
a stack that i call school
i'm creating notebooks for every subject
that i'm taking
and then i'm creating every note new
notes for
every day of the class and every new
piece of information that's coming to me
at that class so again i wish i had this
in high school would have been a lot
easier to keep track of my notes and
find the stuff i was looking for but
that's how i would use it
a great question if you have any other
thoughts on this another question i can
answer for you please feel free to leave
it in the comments below if you guys
like the video give it a thumbs up
but i really do want to hear from you
let me know what you think leave a
comment you have a question about
evernote and how to use it
i'd be happy to make a video response
thank you so much and i'll see you soon
you